c'est quoi un grand maître aux échecs et
bien c'est le titre le plus prestigieux
qui existe et il est extrêmement
difficile à atteindre pour devenir grand
maître il faut réaliser ce que l'on
appelle trois normes de grand maître
international c'est quoi une norme c'est
une performance dans un tournoi d'au
moins neuf parties à minimum 2600 ho
comme ça ne suffisait pas il faut
également que parmi vos neuf adversaires
il y ait au moins trois joueurs qui sont
eux mêm grands maîtres et également deux
joueurs d'une autre fédération que la
votre si vous êtes par exemple français
il faut aussi affronter mettons un
Italien un geéorgien dans votre tournoi
si vous réunissez toute cette condition
vous réalisez une norme de grand matre
il en faut trois et ensuite il faut que
vous parveniez à atteindre les 2500 ho
pour donc gratter le Graal suprême aux
échecs actuellement dans le monde il y
en a que 1813 et en France seulement 55
grands mètres